when it comes to x-men Dark Phoenix it
seems that things aren't looking too
bright the sequels of 2016 x-men
apocalypse Dark Phoenix is finally
nearing as June 7th launch after
stumbling through multiple delays and an
in-depth round of reshoots
sadly whatever it was they filmed
drawing those reshoots may not have done
much to improve the movie's fortunes in
fact the most recent Dark Phoenix
related news could spell even more
trouble
serving as what could be a fatal blow
for the flick according to journalist
Skyler Shula studio 20th Century Fox
recently held a test screening for Dark
Phoenix to collect audience's reactions
to the latest cut and gauge how well the
film might do upon his wide theoretical
release this summer what folks likely
hoped to be a successful pre premiere
showing apparently turned out disastrous
as the screening is said to have
completely bombed this is now the third
Dark Phoenix test showing that has
garnered an unsavory response from
viewers Shula alleged on Twitter
another x-men Doug Phoenix test
screening and guess what's I now have
talked to six people who all went to
three different test screenings and all
of them have told me the screenings were
bad one fan responded I went to one of
the screenings
everybody laughed so hard in a scene
supposed to be so serious
ya know and Shirley replied I think I
know what scene you're referring to and
this isn't even the first time the movie
has failed to well test audiences
earlier this month
Shula relayed that Dark Phoenix was
shaping up to earn a spot in the lower
echelon of Fox's superhero films that
would put it right alongside the slap
together in coherent 2015 Fantastic Four
reboot which is better known online as
fun for stick because of the film's
questionable marketing campaign tweeted
Schule on January 2nd based on what I
have heard this movie could be fun for
stick level bad
[Music]
of course this movies been in trouble
for a long long while if reports are to
be believed the very first crummy Dark
Phoenix test screening apparently took
place sometime before March 2018
that's when Collider published an
exclusive reports claiming that writer
director Simon Kinberg and Fox
executives had screened Dark Phoenix for
a test audience quote to see what was
working on what wasn't and that the
response to the movie pushed the Dark
Phoenix team to delay the movie's
release and order additional photography
while a movie going on with reshoots
doesn't always indicate poor test
screening response it seems to be the
case of Dark Phoenix Screen Rant
reported at the time quote dark
Phoenix's delay has been heavily
influenced by reshoots in response to
test screenings metro UK followed up in
September 2018 that the reaches for a
direct response to quote devastating
test screening reactions Fox's plans for
reshoots were made even more difficult
because of the logistical headaches
involved in reassembling a cast full of
Hollywood a-listers actors like sophie
Turner as Jean Grey Michael Fassbender
as magneto
James McAvoy as Charles Xavier Jennifer
Lawrence's mystique and Nicholas Hoult
as beasts among several others as a
results the reshoots were scheduled for
fall of 2018 pushing Dark Phoenix from
its intended November 2018 launch to a
February 14 to 2019 one reshoots
reportedly began on August 31st 2018 but
may not have wraps before Fox rolled out
the first trailer for Dark Phoenix at
the end of September the footage
revealed that Dark Phoenix have been
delayed a second time moving from
Valentine's Day 2019 to June 7th its
current and unlikely to change debut
dates from there it looks as though Fox
conducted the second test screening for
Dark Phoenix after releasing the first
trailer holding it at the tail end of
2018 or the start of 2019 but judging by
the tweets and fam report sort of kemal
since then it doesn't sound as if the
reshoots have done much to help the
film's reception among test audiences
now
No if Dark Phoenix turns out to be as
rough as test screening attendees say it
is it would be a sad way for the x-men
franchise to go out before the
characters shuffle over to the Marvel
Studios wing of the Walt Disney Company
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more loop of videos about
superhero movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]